sometimes Margot Robbie slaps people to
get away at the time she just writes a
nice letter this is the story of her
journey from Down Under to the top of
the world Margot Robbie was born on July
2nd 1990 on the Gold Coast of Australia
the daughter of a sugarcane magnate her
father Doug left when she was very young
resulting in her strange relationship
between the two but she still has him to
thank for her upbringing on a rural farm
and for her education at private schools
despite having a rich father Robbie and
her mom sarri Kessler struggled to get
by after he left Robbie picked up our
jobs to make ends meet including at the
fast food chain Subway she was initially
tasked with slicing vegetables and
cleaning Cutlery but then she was
promoted to the sandwich line as she
recalled to Vanity Fair in 2014 I was
really good at it I make a mean Subway
the trick is to spread everything evenly
out and cut it so well that there is
never a Bad Bite Robbie's other jobs
included catering warehouse work and
just into the pharmacy then after she
landed her first big acting gig on an
Australian soap opera Subway hired her
to star on a commercial fans outside
Margot his home country of Australia
probably think of her mainly as the
Avatar of American celebs Tonya Harding
or Sharon Tate but back home she's
perhaps even more beloved for her work
on the long-running soap opera Neighbors
on which she played Donna Friedman the
character became a fan favorite thanks
in part to positive by sexual
representation and Robbie's obvious star
power originally cast as a one-off roll
Donna soon became a recurring character
Robbie ended up staying on the show for
three years but then in 2010 she left
Australia to pursue a career in
Hollywood as she told TV week I want to
go to America it's always been my goal
to work in Hollywood it's the one stage
in my life where I have absolutely
nothing holding me down
after Margot Robbie jetted off to
Hollywood she initially landed a few
small movie roles and then everything
changed when director Martin Scorsese
Caster in the 2014 crime epic The Wolf
of Wall Street she starred opposite
Leonardo DiCaprio who's the ranged
energy she matched to beat for beat
Robbie reportedly got the part by
slapping DiCaprio in the face during her
audition a move that was actually not in
the original script as she recalled to
Harper's Bazaar in my head I was like
you have literally 30 seconds left in
this room and if you don't do something
impressive nothing will ever come of it
it's a once in a lifetime chance just
take it and that's that one slap set in
motion a storied career that has seen
Robbie land iconic role after iconic
role when Robbie signed up for 2016
Suicide Squad she didn't know much about
the character of Harley Quinn as she
admitted to the Washington Post I wasn't
familiar with the comics I'd vaguely
heard of them but I had no idea that
there was such a big fan base for Harley
nevertheless had taken Holly was a hit
and the character was even reportedly
the most Googled Halloween costume of
2016. it was a significant departure
from earlier versions of Harley as her
outfit consisted of fishnet a studded
belt and a rips t-shirt reading daddy's
little monster though she initially had
no plans to play Harley again Robbie
left at the opportunity to redeem the
character with a feminist spin in 2020's
Birds of Prey she was also an executive
producer this time around actually noted
to Rotten Tomatoes I thought it'd be
great for the character and I thought
the industry needed a
Go Gang action film plenty of fans fell
in love with Robbie's version of Harley
Quinn in Suicide Squad but if it weren't
for the actress's intense Dedication
that could have been the last time any
of us saw the character on screen so
when it came time to bring her back for
birds of prey she put in the work to
really make it memorable the movie was
less of a sequel to Suicide Squad and
more of her companion piece exploring
Harley's own offbeat life and it forced
Robbie to work in multiple roles at once
as one of the founders of Lucky chap
entertainment she also served as one of
the movie's producers she ultimately
went above and beyond getting all the
pieces together to make the film a
reality and committing to the role so
much that she did most of her own stunts
Robbie wanted to do as many of her own
action sequences herself as possible and
she brought that same energy when she
played Harley once more in 2021's the
suicide squad her biggest scene in that
outing involves gymnastic level
flexibility and she uses her feet to
pick a lock before escaping from a
prison cell and she did almost all the
work on her own
she is like a human Swiss army knife
after Margaret Robbie made the jump from
TV star to movie star she didn't stop
there in between Wolf of Wall Street and
Suicide Squad she was laying the
groundwork for the next phase of her
career as she explained to Harper's
Bazaar in 2018 I didn't want to pick up
another script where I was the wife or
the girlfriend just a catalyst for the
male storyline it was uninspiring her
part in Wolf of Wall Street may have
skyrocketed Robbie to fame but it wasn't
exactly the kind of role she was keen on
playing over and over again so she
decided to solve that problem of
potential type casting by starting our
own Production Studio lucky chap
entertainment began operating in 2014
and it's grown significantly since then
not every one of its films have been
smashing successes but some like I Tonya
and promising young woman have won over
critics General audiences and awards
groups a few years after Wolf of Wall
Street Robbie starred in another film
that was just as important if not more
so in the overall transformation of her
career released in 2017 I Tonya marked a
number of Firsts for her it was the
first time that she'd played her leading
role and it was also the first time that
our production company Lucky chap
entertainment helped bring a project to
life in many ways it was a make or break
moment for the company written by
Stephen Rogers and directed by Craig
Gillespie the biopic follows a life of
figure skater Tanya Harding so Robbie
had to put in some extra work for this
particular movie by learning how to
skate ultimately the actress in that
team struck gold with I Tonya it was a
modest hit at the box office and a major
player at the Oscars with Robbie
nominated for lead actress and her
co-star Alison Johnny winning for best
supporting actress
[Music]
loved
for a minute
based on true stories 2019's bombshell
explores a culture of sexual harassment
that proliferated at Fox News under CEO
Roger Ailes several of the roles are
based on actual people but Margot
Robbie's part of Kayla was a composite
character with multiple real-life
Inspirations Robbie has admitted that
bombshell was something of a wake-up
call for her as she told Variety in
November 2022 and realized that I as a
person with an established position in
the industry financially set up and
self-sufficient and didn't know the
definition of sexual harassment and
that's shocking Robbie also told
Entertainment Weekly that she had a
tough time getting inside Kayla's head
and when she was on set the work didn't
get any easier as she put it the
emotional side was difficult in a
different kind of way all of that hard
work ultimately paid off though but the
bombshell earning Robbie her second
Oscar nomination Margot Robbie is a
massive fan of director Quentin
Tarantino way back before she broke big
she made a plan to write to maletta when
she felt that she was ready to star in
one of his films that moment came in
2017 after she saw her own performance
in I Tonya so she finally wrote that
letter that she'd been thinking about
for years and it just so happened to
land in front of Tarantino as he was
beginning to think about casting for his
next movie 2019's Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood Robbie didn't know it at the
time but several of Tarantino's friends
had already floated her name for the
role of Sharon Tate and so he reached
out and invited Robbie to his home where
she spent hours reading through the
script it just finished by the time she
was done she was ready to play the role
and he was more than willing to offer it
to her I'm in the movie I'm Sharon Tate
as an actor producer and business owner
Margot Robbie doesn't exactly have much
time to herself but she does have a plan
for what to do and work finally comes to
an end as she admitted to Vogue in 2023
all I want to do was live on a train
Robbie derives quite a bit of joy in
sitting back and staring out the window
while her train rolls through the
countryside in 2022 she and her husband
Tom Ackley took a ride on the Orient
Express which had been a long time goal
of Robbie's to even spent the trip
watching the 1974 movie version of
murder on the Orient Express and seeing
how it travels compared as it turns out
an obsession with trains might be a bit
of a family trait back in 2019 Robbie
took a trip back to a native Australia
to spend some time with her sister
rather than relaxing by a pool they
hopped on board the country's famous gun
train which makes a four day trip to the
Australian Outback Margot Robbie has
already gotten to work with some of her
biggest Hollywood Heroes like Martin
Scorsese and Quentin Tarantino but she
hasn't quite crossed every dream
partnership off her wishlist in a 2022
Vanity Fair profile she mentions some
notable directors she'd like to work
with including Paul Thomas Sanderson
bong Joon ho and Celine ski armor at
this point in her career it's hard to
imagine that Robbie would have much
difficulty getting to work with anyone
else she wants she's one of the biggest
stars in Hollywood and as a producer at
lucky chap entertainment she has plenty
of say about what project she's going to
work on next after all despite the
enviable position she finds herself in
today Robbie still feels just as excited
about getting to work if she did during
her early days on Australian TV as she
admitted to netapporte in 2018. I've
been on sets for pretty much the last 10
years and I still walk on and think this
is so cool look at that that's amazing
oh my gosh Margot Robbie might seem like
the perfect actress to play Barbie but
that decision wasn't always obvious to
her as she admitted to Vogue in May 2023
this is going to sound stupid but I
really didn't even think about playing
Barbie until years into developing the
project Robbie's work on the Barbie
movie actually began from a producer's
perspective she didn't really have much
of a personal history of the Mattel toys
so it wasn't exactly something she'd
been dreaming of her whole life
I think we want more than anything
everyone to kind of have the experience
they want to have probably helped get
director gerweg involved in the project
and the two of them started
brainstorming ideas so who fit their
idea of the character the first person
on that list was actually Gal Gadot as
they believed that she embodied Barbie
energy ultimately there ended up being
multiple versions of Barbies in the film
although Godot isn't among them and with
Robbie taking the lead she fits into the
role as well as Barbie fits into her
dream house while it wasn't the plan
from the beginning it definitely seems
like it was always fated to go this way
laughs
foreign